Flambierte Köpfe… Farbeimer als Wurfgeschosse
… und ein Waschbecken unter Hochspannung.
Wenn uns Kevin McAllister
eins beigebracht hat, dann,
wie man ein Haus verteidigt! Aber wie gefährlich,
oder sogar tödlich, sind eigentlich die Fallenaus
„Home Alone“? Das klären wir heute und
zwar gemeinsam mit Deutschlands bekanntestem
Kriminalbiologen Dr. Mark Benecke.
Tach zusammen,Jack Pop hier.
Weihnachten ist die Zeit
von Mandarinen, Pfefferkuchen und eine meiner
liebsten Filme: „Kevin – Allein zu Haus.
Kleine Quizfrage an dieser Stelle: wie viele Filme gibt es eigentlich insgesamt? Schreibt mir
Euren Tipp mal in die Kommentare und
am Ende der Folge lösen wir das auf.
Aber am bekanntesten sind
natürlich die beiden ersten Teile,
in denen Kevin selber noch mitspielt. Seit
1990 halten sich die Filme hartnäckig im
Feiertagsprogramm. In meinem Kopf ist
aber immer die Frage hängengeblieben,
wie brutal Kevins Fallen bitte sind.
Im Film sieht man die Einbrecher
Harry und Marv permanent verunglücken undschreien. Und wenn es um Verletzungen und Fallen
geht, dann kann uns hier auf dem Kanal natürlichnur einer aushelfen, nämlich Dr. Mark Benecke.
Unter den deutschen Kriminalbiologen ist MarkBenecke definitiv der Alpha-Kevin. Er weiß
auf jeden Fall, was brandgefährlich ist. Mark hat uns schon eingeschätzt, wie tödlich die Fallen
aus den „SAW“-Horrorfilmen sind. Klar also, dasser uns auch jetzt bei „Home Alone“ helfen muss.
Mark, schön, dass Du wieder da
bist. - Ich freue mich auch.
Wir haben es hier für Dich schön
hergerichtet, Noch ist es weihnachtlich,
aber gleich wird es brutal. Denn wir haben eineVideobotschaft bekommen. Und zwar von Silke,von den Filmgorillas.
Die haben sich füruns nämlich mal die Filme angeschaut und
die 4 brutalsten Fallen von Kevin ausgesucht.
Ihr holt Euch jetzt mal bitte eine RiesenportionEis
mit Marshmallows, denn hier kommt Nummer 1.
Hi Mark, Hi Jack. Die ikonischste aller Fallen
sind für mich die pendelnden Farbeimer. Denn mit
ihnen kommt die Einbrecherjagd erst so richtig inSchwung
Kevin befestigt sie mit Stricken oben
am Treppengeländer und verwandelt sie so in
Wurfgeschosse oder eher in „Pendel-Geschosse“,
die mit voller Wucht ins Gesicht knallen
und sie so von der Treppe schubsen. Autsch!
Wir haben hier richtige „Science vs. Fiction“-
Farbeimer mitgebracht. Die sind ein bisschen
kleiner als im Film. Bei Kevin würde ich sagen,
sind es schon so 5 bis 6kg Was passiert, wenn
dir so ein Ding direkt vors Gesicht knallt?
Du hast ein echtes Problem. Die Knochen sind hier
dünn, hier oben an der Seite und an den Augen.
Jeder, der schon gegen die Glasscheibe gelaufen
ist der weiß, dass die Nase auch sehr empfindlichist.
Und das führt natürlich dazu, dass die
Knochen Risse oder Du Knochenbrüche haben kannst.
Aber selbst, wenn das nicht passieren würde,weil Du der harte Kerl bist, dann wird der
Schädel natürlich hinten geschleudert. Und
dadurch kann es zu Wirbelbrüchen kommen.
Oder zu dem, was manche Leute vielleicht von
Autounfällen kennen – einem Schleudertrauma.
Das kann echt gefährlich sein. Manchmal tritt das
ein bisschen verzögert auf. Aber dadurch, dass das
Rückenmark da drin ist, kann es wirklich zu sehr
schweren Verletzungen führen. Man hat mittlerweile
sogar Achterbahnen umgebaut, damit die
Beschleunigung in den Loopings nicht mehr so großist.
Damit Du eben kein Schleudertrauma kriegst.
Vor Jahrzehnten gab es sogar mal den Verein der
„Achterbahn-Looping-Geschädigten“ deswegen, weil
das wirklich langfristige Schäden hervorrufe kann.
Das klingt schon mal sehr unangenehm. Im zweitenTeil macht Kevin ja noch ein Upgrade zu dieser
Falle. Da kommt ein riesen Metallrohr
auf die Gangster zu, dass kriegen die
ins Gesicht. Das hat ja nochmal mehr Kraft.
- Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wenn Dir dieses Rohr
mit dem Schwung, den man in dem Film sieht,
wirklich ins Gesicht fliegen würde…
Das würde Dich wahrscheinlich erst einmal komplett
ausknocken. Und wenn Du dann hinfällst,
hättest Du wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr,
wie man das im Film sieht, noch die Energie,
den Kopf hoch zu halten. Du würdest
wahrscheinlich direkt mit dem Kopf aufschlagen.
Und diese Schläge auf den Kopf sind auch bei
Boxern mittelfristig gefürchtet. Da breitet
sich die Stoßwelle durch den Kopf aus.
Also erst kommt die von der einen Seite,
dann von der anderen Seite. Und selbst, wenn dann
der Schädel gar nicht gebrochen wäre, treffen die
sich irgendwo im Gehirn. Und an der Stelle
prallen die Stoßwellen aufeinander. Und dann
hast Du an der Stelle Nervenuntergänge. Den Rest
kann man sich wahrscheinlich vorstellen.
Also das ist wirklich in jeder Hinsicht richtig Scheiße.
Und dass die mit Kopfschmerzen echt Probleme
haben, das sehen wir im Film die ganze Zeit.
Die kriegen ein Bügeleisen ins Gesicht,
Werkzeuge auf dem Kopf und in Teil 2 wird
Kevin richtig perfide. Da schmeißt er fette
Ziegelsteine vom Dach runter, Marv kriegt die
volle Latte auf die Stirn. Das ist heftig!
Das ist mega heftig. Also ich glaube, jeder kann
es ja mal ausprobieren, wie so ein Ziegelstein zersplittert,
wenn man den von einem Dach
runterschmeißt. Man lernt schon als Kind,
das man noch nicht mal Steinchen irgendwo vom Hochhaus
oder vom Balkon runterschmeißen soll, weil die
natürlich immer mehr Wumms kriegen, wenn die von
der Schwerkraft angezogen werden. Und wenn er das
vor den Kopf bekommt, jetzt mal ganz unabhängig
von Genickverletzungen oder Schädelbrüchen,
können natürlich auch Adern reißen. Dann blutet es
oder das ganze Gehirn wird durchgeschüttelt.
Dir wird super superschlecht, du kriegst mörderische
Kopfschmerzen, du bist total desorientiert.
Das ist richtig unangenehm. Und wenn die Adern bluten,
dann kann das auch länger dauern. Dann gibt es
eine Blutung und dann ist das raumfordernd,
so nennt man das, dann fordert das immer
mehr Raum und nach und nach lassen dann Funktionen von Deinem Körper nach und hast Du weißt aber
gar nicht was und warum. Denn im Gehirn spürst dukeine richtigen Schmerzen. Also die Kopfschmerzen
sind noch etwas Anderes. Das geht schief.
Bitte keine Backsteine auf Menschen werfen.
Und ich habe mir hier immer gedacht: Warum macht Kevin das? Er muss doch wissen, dass das,
auch nach Deiner Einschätzung, tödlich ist.
- Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also wenn ich Kids sehenwürde,
gehe ich an vielen vorbei. Wenn ichKids sehe, die eine Wasserbombe in der Hand haben,
sage ich nichts. Aber wenn ich Kinder sehenwürde, die Steine runterwerfen würden,
das wäre der Moment, wo ich stehenbleiben undausnahmsweise Mal zum Helden werden würde.
Ein mahnendes Wort!
- Ein bisschen mehr als ein mahnendes Wort!
Wir können an dieser Stelle festhalten: so schnellwie im Film würden die beiden auf jeden Fall nicht
wieder aufstehen. Die würden nach den Farbeimern
mindestens ein bisschen Bettruhe verordnet
bekommen und nach den Ziegelsteinen wahrscheinlich
direkt unter die Erde gebracht werden.
Noch bevor die Einbrecher überhaupt im Haus sind,
tappt Harry schon an der Eingangstür in eine heißeFalle.
Kevin hat nämlich einen elektrischen
Grillanzünder an den Türknauf gehangen
und diesen so zum Glühen gebracht. Als Harry jetzt
also nichtsahnend an den Türknauf fasst,
brennt sich ein fettes McAllister M in seine Hand.
Wir haben versucht, einen elektrischen
Grillanzünder zu bekommen und das hier
gefunden. Sieht nicht ganz so aus wie im Film,
aber guck mal. Es ist ein schönes
„McAllister“- oder „Mark Benecke“-M.
Oder MDR, mein Lieblingssender,
oder auch ein W wie Wissen.
Es macht auf jeden Fall genau das gleiche,
nämlich Hitze. Und wenn so ein Ding jetzt glüht,
dann muss es so um die 500ºC haben. Wenn
Harry damit der Hand dran packt, tut das weh.
Das tut weh. Was bedeutet, dass Du nicht
diese superhohe Hitze hast, die Dir direkt
eine weiße Verbrennung reinknallt, wo die Nerven
tot sind. Dann spürst Du nämlich gar nichts mehr.
So gesehen ist es noch ein bisschen besser,
mit dem Nachteil, dass es total wehtut und
Narben erzeugt. Also das ist vielleicht
eine zweitgradige Verbrennung, die er
sich da eingehandelt hat. Aber es ist wirklichsehr, sehr unschön und jeder weiß, auch an der
Hand hat man ganz viele Nervenenden und spürt
ganz viel Schmerz. Da tut es besonders weh.
Und das ist auch richtig verewigt. Im zweitenTeil sehen wir das in seiner Handinnenfläche.
Was sind denn da die Langzeitfolgen?
- Du wirst ein böser Mensch…
Schwierigkeiten kannst Du vor allen Dingen überall da kriegen,
wo Du die Finger zusammenziehen möchtest. Du
hast ja da drin, dann irgendwelche Sehnen,
dann muss die Haut natürlich auch beweglichsein.
Und man kann natürlich versuchen, bestimmte
Therapiemethoden zu machen um das Gewebe wieder zulockern
Aber ich glaube, jeder, der schon mal
eine großflächige Verbrennung gesehen hat, kann
sich vorstellen, da helfen Salben, Cremes
und Massagen wahrscheinlich nur begrenzt.
Da müsste man wieder Operationen
machen. Dadurch kann es wieder zu
Entzündungen kommen. Also ein ganz wichtiger
Bestandteil eines Körpers, nämlich die Hände,
funktioniert wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so gut.
Und ist es denn clever, was Harry macht?
Dass er quasi mit der Hand, die heißt ist, direkt
in den Schnee packt, um die abzukühlen?
Eigentlich ist das schon gut, weil dadurch
zieht sich irgendwie alles zusammen. Und
Und es tut auch weniger weh, im ersten Moment
Aber dadurch, dass es sich später wieder
auf die normale Temperatur erwärmen muss,
Du kannst Deine Hand ja nicht ewig langekühlen.
Da tut es dann umso mehr. Also ich
würde sagen, es ist beides gleich schlecht.
Ich würde es kühlen, erst mal, weil ich dann
erst mal kurz meine Ruhe hätte. Aber am Ende
des Tages tut es dann noch mehr weh.
Während Marv permanent Schläge auf den
Kopf bekommt, muss Harry sich immer wieder mit
Feuer herumschlagen. Der heiße Türknauf war ja
schon heftig, aber die nächste Falle wird noch
einmal eine Stufe härter. Denn eigentlich möchte
Harry nur eine Lampe anmachen. Doch in diesem
Moment flambiert eine Lötlampe seine Kopfhaut.
Und das merkt Harry erst gar nicht. Erst 20
Sekunden später probiert er, seinen brennenden
Kopf in einer Toilettenschüssel zu löschen. Doch
da hat er nicht mit Kevins „follow-up-Falle“
gerechnet. Denn in der Toilettenschüssel
befindet sich brennbare Flüssigkeit.
Und so löst Harry eine mittelgroße Explosion aus.
Das Ding merke ich jetzt schon im Gesicht und es
ist noch deutlich weiter weg, als Harry seine
Mütze auf dem Kopf hat. Die fängt Feuer.
Er müsste doch sofort merken, dass die brennt.
Vielleicht nicht sofort. Weil am Anfang,
wenn jetzt nur diese Baumwolle oder was
das ist, brennt, ist es vielleicht noch
nicht ganz so auffällig. Aber die
Haare darunter brennen blitzschnell
weg. Kann man mit einem einzelnen Haar mal
ausprobieren, das ist wirklich eindrucksvoll.
Und spätestens dann merkt er das auf jeden
Fall. Das führt auch dazu, dass es im
Nervensinne brennt. Du kannst dann Schwellungen
kriegen und es tut total weh. Also ja, klar,
dann merkst Du das auf jeden Fall.
- Womit müsste er dann rechnen?
Also was machen die Verbrennungen? Was für
einen Schaden ist da am Kopf zu erwarten?
Also wenn die Haut jetzt wirklich tief
wegbrennt und dann abstirbt, dann müsste
er in eine Brandklinik gehen. Dann müsste man
das versorgen. Ich weiß nicht. Irgendwo anders
versuchen, Haut- oder Gewebeteile herzukriegen.
Das entzündet sich garantiert mega. Also dann
müsste an einer anderen Stelle, am besten von
ihm selbst Haut entnommen werden, wenn er keine
künstliche Haut eingepflanzt bekommen kann. Das
heißt, er liegt dann in einer total abgeschottetenStation.
Es tut weh. Es ist alles weiß, er
ist einsam… wirklich sehr, sehr unangenehm.
Und Harry ist ja eigentlich sehr clever, er
will das ja löschen. Er sieht die Toilette,
packt sich kopfüber da rein. Blöderweise
ist da ein Brandbeschleuniger drin. Dann gibt
es eine fette Explosion. Deine Einschätzung?
- Da ist vieles falsch. Also zunächst mal,
wenn ich denken würde, da wäre Wasser drin und
das würde was nützen, würde ich mich natürlich
hinknien und sofort den Kopf herein tun und
da keinen Handstand drüber machen.
Das ist das Erste. Das zweite ist, wenn ich
den Handstand mache, fängt natürlich die ganze
restliche Kleidung auch noch an zu brennen.
Das ist also eine total sinnlose Idee.
Dann habe ich vielleicht meinen Kopf gelöscht, aber
der Rest brennt. Und das einzig, sagen wir mal
„Gute“ daran ist, es würde nicht explodieren.
Das kann man leider nicht selber ausprobieren.
Nicht selber ausprobieren!
Wenn man wenige Tropfen Benzin oder irgendetwas
Explosives nimmt und dass in einer großen Menge,
sagen wir mal Luftsauerstoff-Gemisch einbringt,
dann kann es hochgehen. Also explodieren.
Die Flüssigkeit an sich, die brennt aber „nur“.
Das heißt, die fliegt nicht in die Luft, weil da
nicht genügend Sauerstoff oder sonst was drin ist.
Das ist die einzig halbwegs gute Nachricht hier.
Dass es nicht gleich alles in die Luft fliegt.
Das heißt, Harry müsste wahrscheinlich auch wieder
ein paar Wochen ins Krankenhaus. Aber zumindest
würde nicht das ganze Haus in die Luft fliegen.
Wie hinterlistig Kevin ist, merkt man immer dann,
wenn er Fallen baut, die aufeinander aufbauen.
Hier hat er Marv gerade mit Farbe übergossen
und ihm war natürlich klar, dass Marv danach
zum Waschbecken gehen würde. Das hat Kevin
aber unter Strom gesetzt. Und als Marv jetzt das
Wasser aufdrehen will, bekommt er von Kevin einen
Elektroschock verpasst. Ganze 18 Sekunden lang.
Kevin war hier ganz clever. Denn in dem Haus woer ist,
ist ja eigentlich keine Stromleitung
vorhanden. Es ist ein Abrisshaus. Und deswegen
nimmt er ein Gerät zum Lichtbogenschweißen. Also
wo man ordentlich Strom braucht. Mark, wenn ich
das an ein Waschbecken anschließe und Marv dann
daran packt… ist das realistisch dargestellt?
Das er dann so zittert und die Funken fliegen?
- Also da stimmt mehreres nicht.
Eigentlich müsste eventuell auch eine Sicherung
kommen, falls ein vorhanden ist,
okay in den USA in einem im Abrisshaus
vielleicht nicht. Aber es ist so dargestellt,
als ob er an eine Steckdose fassen würde. Dann
ziehen sich nämlich die Muskeln zusammen. Das ist
eine Funktion des lebenden Körpers, da krampft
er sich zusammen und deswegen kannst du leider
auch nicht loslassen, was du besser loslassen
solltest. Weil deine Hände zusammengezogensind.
Was übrigens auch dazu führt, dass
das Herz nicht mehr richtig funktioniert.
Und wenn man 18 Sekunden in eine Steckdose
fassen würde, das wäre ganz, ganz schlecht.
Also das wäre Wechselstrom. Wenn es aber das
echte Gerät wäre, was da dargestellt ist,
wäre es Gleichstrom. Das wäre eigentlich fast
noch schlimmer, weil, dann kriegt man nicht dieses
Muskel zusammenziehen, sondern dann verbruzelst
Du direkt, und das ist nicht lustig gemeint.
Das sehen wir immer wieder, wenn Kinder auf
Laster klettern und dann in die Nähe einer
Starkstromleitung kommen. Und dann haben die
richtig krasse Verbrennungen. Dann ja krümmt sich
das jetzt nicht mehr durch den lebenden Körper
zusammen, durch das Spannen, sondern krümmt sich
das bestenfalls noch durch die Hitze zusammen,
weil die Sehnen sich zusammenziehen, weil Du dann
nämlich verkokelt bist. Also dargestellt sind
eigentlich zwei verschiedene Sachen, die beide
aus verschiedenen Gründen gleich schlecht sind.
Und er ist ja auch noch mit Farbe angeschmiert:
Das heißt, er ist nass. Das ist
ja nochmal schlimmer, selbst,
wenn da jetzt nicht so viel Strom drauf wäre.
- Genau! Der Widerstand ist natürlich geringer,
als wenn Du trockene Haut hast. Dann bedeutet das,
dass der Strom nicht so schnell übertreten kann,
wenn ich etwas anfasse was elektrisch ist.
Je nasser ich bin, zum Beispiel durch Farbe,
umso schneller geht es natürlich. Und umso
schneller tritt der Strom in meinen Körper
ein und kann da seine Wirkung entfalten.
Bei echtem „Starkstrom“ wäre es auch egal,
da nützt es Dir auch nix mehr,
wenn Du trockene Haut hast.
Beim „an die Steckdose fassen“, was hier jetzt
nicht richtig dargestellt ist, könnte Dir das
vielleicht ein bisschen Spielraum geben.
- Aber bei dem Gerät, was wir da sehen,
und bei den Stromstärken, die wir erwarten
können, müssten wir hier leider festhalten:
Das wäre sein letzter Einbruch gewesen.
Wenn wir den Film schauen, sind wir natürlich
auf der Seite von Kevin. Aber wenn wir ehrlich
sind, sind seine Methoden super brutal,
für einen Kinderfilm. Warum macht es uns
trotzdem so viel Spaß, da zu zugucken?
Warum lachen wir darüber,
wenn ich Leute brutal wehtun?
Das fragen wir uns natürlich ganz oft.
Je länger Du, wie ich, in Kriminalistik
arbeitest umso mehr fragst Du Dich auch „Why?“.
Also ein fieser Grund ist natürlich, dass viele
Menschen auch Gewaltphantasien haben, möchten aber
die Guten bleiben. Dann brauchst Du jemanden Böse,
der das erleidet, wo Du immer sagen kannst:
„Hey, das hat er sich selbst eingehandelt.
Da kann ich jetzt auch nichts für.“
Das ist der eine Grund. Sieht man auch
bei Hinrichtungen früher. Das war ein
riesen Spektakel. Gleichzeitig ist es
vielleicht auch eine Warnung. Weihnachten
ist alles gut aber vielleicht ja doch
nicht. Immer noch wachsam bleiben.
Bleib wehrsam und achte darauf,
wenn irgendwas nicht richtig funktioniert. Da
gibt es wirklich einen ganzen Blumenstrauß von
Möglichkeiten, warum Menschen Ungerechtigkeit
und übertrieben Gewaltausübung ganz gut finden.
Das begleitet uns weltweit
in der Kriminalistik überall.
Und am Ende ist es ja auch völlig
übertrieben dargestellt. Das nimmt
ein bisschen die Krassheit daraus.
Das ist wie bei den Kinderfilmen,
die vielleicht manche noch kennen, wie bei „Tomund Jerry“ und allen anderen, wo die sich ständig
auf den Kopf schlagen. Plattgedrückt und alles
Mögliche in die Länge gezogen. Dadurch ist es
natürlich übertrieben aber am Ende passiert
nicht viel. Selbst wenn die zwischendrin
mal ein Skelett sind. Am Ende sind sie doch
wieder vollständig und können wieder gehen
und haben keine Bewegungseinschränkungen und so.
Dann ist es vielleicht „nicht so schlimm“ gewesen.
Unterhaltend sind die Filme ja allemal.
Da müssen wir übrigens unser kleines
Rätsel auflösen. Es gibt tatsächlich
6 Filme in der „Home Alone“-Reihe.
Wenn Ihr mir nicht glaubt, ich
pinn Euch einen Kommentar an.
Mark, Dir vielen Dank fürs Erklären…
… es war mir ein weihnachtliches Glitzervergnügen!
Vergesst bitte nicht zu abonnieren
und das Glöckchen zu drücken.
Dann können wir uns nämlich bald wiedersehen.
Ich würde mich drauf freuen, bis dann!
Ein riesiger Dank geht auch raus an Silke von
den Filmgorillas und wenn Ihr hier klickt,
kommt Ihr zu denen auf den Kanal. Dort findet
Ihr ein Feiertags-Special, wo Silke ihre drei
liebsten Weihnachtsfilme vorstellt.
Kevin ist auch mit dabei und falls
Ihr Weihachten eher hasst, dort findet Ihr
auch drei richtig gute Anti-Weihnachtsfilme.